while there aren't too many concrete
details surrounding the master of the
mystic arts sequel thus far there is
plenty for hungry fans to speculate
about one thing is for certain
whatever Marvel decides to do with the
good doctor audiences everywhere can
expect something strange Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness may not
have started production yet but that's
never stopped Marvel from knowing
exactly when a movie will hit theaters
at the 2019 San Diego Comic Con Marvel
head Kevin Feige unveiled details on
phase 4 of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
including official release dates for all
of the company's major upcoming projects
in 2020 and 2021 this announcement
included a May 7th 2021 release date for
the freshly-minted Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness the decision to
move Doctor Strange from November to May
showcases just how popular the character
has become in the past few years while
November in the beginning of the holiday
season is certainly a traditional home
for some major films may still holds
more prestige in Hollywood circles as
the beginning of the blockbuster season
Marvel clearly has a lot of faith in
this particular sequel to put it at the
forefront of its summer 2021 slate who's
laughing now Marvel Studios turned heads
back in 2014 when they announced the
hiring of Scott Derrickson to direct the
then upcoming Doctor Strange before
helming the big-budget superhero flick
Derek's ins career consisted pretty
strictly a horror fare from The Exorcism
of Emily Rose too sinister to deliver us
from evil the director cut his teeth on
flashy films intended to pry to V goers
despite his unassuming track record
derrickson turned out to be an astute
pick with an eye for striking visuals
proving to be an essential asset to the
project Doctor Strange has a look and
feel that is unique in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe definitely blending
martial arts choreography and surreal
digital imagery that would make
inceptions Christopher Nolan blush in
December 2018 Marvel officially brought
derrickson back to help Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness with
derrickson back and with Benedict
Cumberbatch returning as the sorcerer
supreme the future of the series is
clearly in solid hands there may not be
an official plot synopsis for Doctor
Strange too but plenty of potential
story hints have been dropped by some
behind-the-scenes people who are in the
in an April 2016 interview with double
toasted dr. strange co-writer see Robert
Cargill stated that Marvel felt some of
the initial ideas he and Erickson had
for the first film highlighted too much
of the quote/unquote weird stuff
associated with the character to
introduce the hero they reasoned the
origin story would have to ease
audiences into his bizarre world
[Music]
miss destroy however marvel did tell the
pair to hold on to their more outlandish
ideas for potential future films in the
franchise referencing the Dark Knight's
director scott derrickson told den of
geek in 2016 what made the Dark Knight
so great was that the origin story of
Batman had been well told and then it
was time to bring in a villain where you
really got to go deep and not just the
Joker also two-face
it was a more visceral experience I'd
love to be able to do that for Doctor
Strange well on stage at the 2019 San
Diego Comic Con derrickson said quote
we're gonna make the first scary MCU
film which in addition to the
announcement of a new blade project
raises the following question just how
horrific will Marvel that their
franchises get potentially pretty grim
especially considering the fact that
derrickson has been playing with the
idea of introducing Marvel villain
nightmare the demonic ruler of The
Nightmare Realm into the MCU spooky
stuff Marvel fans got a pretty exciting
surprise during the 2019 San Diego
comic-con when it was revealed that
elizabeth Olsen Scarlet Witch would be
joining Cumberbatch and company for
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness when you have a strong sorcerer
it also helps when you have a strong
Witch and The Scarlet Witch is appearing
in this movie alongside ER
seeing as there are no Avengers flicks
on the upcoming docket and the fact that
her own powers draw upon the mystic arts
it makes sense that Scarlet Witch would
join Doctor Strange in the horror tint
sequel benedict wong has also been
confirmed for Doctor Strange 2 returning
as strangest trusty sidekick the
character also coincidentally named Wong
a prolific performer on stage screen and
film has been steadily acting since the
early 1990s and has appeared in numerous
sci-fi films including sunshine moon
Prometheus and the Martian so we've got
a beloved Avenger joining forces with
the sorcerer supreme and we've got a fan
favorite supporting character lending
his talent to the big screen once more
but the looming question on everyone's
mind is what about Chua tell @ g o4 as
Mordo we still think there will be no
consequences strange no price to pay
we broke our rules just like the
post-credits scene at the end of Doctor
Strange certainly paints more dough as a
villain and sets him up to be a baddie
in future films but whether that comes
to fruition in the sequel remains to be
seen the state of the MCU as we know it
would be dramatically different if
Stephen strange had not convinced Tony
Stark that he was the key to saving the
universe for a character who had barely
been introduced a year and a half before
Avengers infinity wars release
Cumberbatch's Strange had a shockingly
important role to play in the unraveling
of the end of Marvel's infinity saga but
now that endgame has come and gone
breaking box-office records along the
way what does the future of the MCU hold
for Stephen strange earth has lost three
of its greatest defenders with the
deaths of Tony Stark and Natasha
Romanoff not to mention the time travel
induced agent of Steve Rogers Clint
Barton seems content to permanently
retire after all the chaos and Thor is
out in space with Marvel's other super
team the guardians of the galaxy good
Stephen strange step up to fill the
heroic void left in Thanos his wake only
time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]